that's when I came up with Expendables
where you can't do it alone but I'll
take together I'll take a group of
actors that are not doing so well and
you put it all together and I got the
idea when I took my wife to a rock and
roll Revival where you have like 20
groups and each one was worse than the
next but together it was an interesting
ticket like oh look at this and I
thought why don't I do the same I take
all these guys who perhaps on their own
were struggling including myself put
them together and that like I want to
see how this turns out this is kind of
interesting which creates a a bomb that
that takes out this whole section pulls
up Eric Roberts goes uh-oh Chopper gun
he bails it goes the opposite direction
and that's when we say head to our
finale now did you just make this up
just now yeah